[موسيقى]
في أعماق جبال اليابان الريفية
وسط الينابيع الساخنة في ياماناشي هو
أقدم فندق في العالم
[موسيقى]
ضيوف سابقون من بينهم
الإمبراطور الحالي لليابان [
موسيقى]
أنا الرئيس الثالث والخمسين لفندق هوت سبرينغز هذا
وقد نقل الفندق ثلاثة  مرات بعد
الكوارث الطبيعية ولكن التاريخ لا يزال
حياً ومرئيًا إلى حد كبير اليوم
[الموسيقى]
بالإضافة إلى صوت الجهير الخاص بنا منذ 1300 عام ،
أضفنا أنابيب لجلب
الينابيع الساخنة المياه إلى الغرف الفردية
[الموسيقى]
لدينا أيضًا المطبخ الياباني التقليدي
من  الجبال والأنهار المحلية
[موسيقى]
نأمل أن يحتضن ضيوفنا كل عنصر
من عناصر هذا الفندق
في عام 2011 ، تم اختيار فندق نيشياما أونسن كيونغان
كأقدم فندق في العالم من قبل موسوعة غينيس
للأرقام القياسية التي
أخبرني سلفي أن أكون سيد
الفندق ولا تتشتت انتباهه مع
الآخرين  إن المشاريع التي
تضمن بقاء هذا الفندق الذي يبلغ من العمر 1300 عام
على هذا النحو هو واجبي بصفتي الرئيس الثالث والخمسين ،
في اليوم الذي أسلم فيه
عملي رسميًا إلى الرئيس الرابع والخمسين
عندما أديت واجبي هنا
[موسيقى]